hey and welcome to let's play roller
coaster in three Episode because the
Oyen something we are still not done and
people are still more tired of this
let's play in which I do the same thing
every damn time
so let's let's keep going in this
episode we're going to do some of that
boring stuff you know building buildings
building Spanish buildings in this case
okay and honestly though I really don't
know if this building was in the end
worth it if it was actually good because
something I did I did with this building
was really just a very bad idea that was
jump into it right away without actually
practicing with stuff and I know that I
always say like oh yes I practice things
before I do let's play videos and stuff
like that and to be to be very honest
you don't really see that usually but
now I didn't practice I think you can
clearly see that I didn't practice the
theme at all because holy [ __ ] this
looks terrible in the end okay now it
doesn't look terrible alright but I was
just dreaming and messing with this
building and even in the end it came out
all right especially for theme park I
feel like it definitely does its job but
it's nothing outstanding it's nothing
that I really think like oh yeah this is
really what I want to have so I might
eventually in the end maybe change this
but this building is not the only thing
that it's going to be coming around in
this episode it's also kind of about the
planning of general things I need to
start heading into areas like those for
I haven't planned anything except on the
Main Street in wall the coach they're
going through there is that one drawing
and a couple of other ideas that I have
here in there which is this very chaotic
and I can't organize anything for [ __ ]
so I really need to get to the planning
aspect in rollercoaster country as well
and that's also going to be a small part
of this video because the first area
that I wanted to do was the
Mediterranean Mediterranean area with
the Greek Spanish and Italian ish themes
and these are not going to be mixed of
course but I hope that I might be able
to get all of them in but it's gonna be
tough with the Greek theme because it is
indeed quite different but so far I
think it should kind of work out with
this building I should I should talk
about this filming honestly I never do
that like I never talk about the things
that are actually going on damn it
focus this building is just okay I
wanted to have something on this corner
because this was the only corner I think
where I can actually get a Mediterranean
because like I said I once around the
square to get all buildings of all kinds
of places in the world to represent the
well area in the park with that theme so
since this is the corner where I'll have
the Mediterranean theme I'll have a
Mediterranean building over here but on
the other side of the part I already
want to have either a Dutch or Flemish H
building
maybe both and who really cares but the
other thing is that it's really hard to
get those facades rights especially
because there's many themes next to each
other that you wouldn't really place
next to each other in other cases and
like I said I'm really stepping out of
my comfort zone with this team and while
this is a good thing because I don't
want to stay in the comfort zone as not
only is it just boring to do the same
thing over and over again
it is also a pitfall and it might
actually become a bad thing after a
while since you do the same things you
start using the same sets over and over
again and you really get a lot loss of
creativity and there's not really much
going on whereas usually when you start
a new theme that you haven't really
tried you try to mess with the sets and
eventually you really get something
awesome just by messing with stuff and
you find out new things so that's just
always a great development but in this
case I went into this building quite
unprepared in the theme with just a
general idea in mind and mind you I also
don't think that the Spanish theme in
general is great for facades especially
like this because a facade building is
something completely different from like
a house in the middle of a forest or
something like that which is the type of
while building that you would normally
find in Spain at least in with the theme
and there is a distinct difference
between a facade building and just to
run random standalone buildings
basically what I was trying to say and
to get that very distinct Spanish this
into a building with just a facade in a
way that you would have them in the
middle of many cities is kind of hard so
I wanted to get something that's kind of
in-between it's both a facade in a way
but it could also work as a standalone
building but this is also where I think
the building's main weaknesses that I
have right now it's not really clear
what it's trying to be like there's a
couple roofs and stuff all around the
thing which is meant to be looking
interesting but then again it also just
like this building is here to be a
building but it's not really adding
anything substantial to the facade as a
whole so I might redo some things about
this building maybe in the future just
completely remove it but since this is
something that you know I've worked on
in an episode and it really would feel
like a shame if I wanted to remove that
given that I've already had an episode
in which it appears I'll just let it
stay for now kind of build around it
maybe it's going to work in the end with
it with the scenery around it but I
think I'm still not really happy about
it
and it's always hard to say this
especially because I know that there are
people out there who would think well I
can't do [ __ ] like this either so what's
the big deal and I would almost feel
like I'm downgrading other people if I'm
downgrading my work if they feel like
I'm better than them which is definitely
something which I don't want to say and
everybody's got their own thing and
everybody's got their own theme and
that's why you can't really well judge
things like that's all so that's the
reason why this but I was not really
working out too well but yeah I
shouldn't complain about my own my about
my own things it was still kind of fun
to build this building and if anything I
would like to say that removing things
is never not ever a completely terrible
thing in rollercoaster can three that
you should despise and that if you work
on a building for three hours and you in
the end remove it and just completely
leave it out of your park it is not a
waste of building this every single
building that you build especially when
you're new to the theme is a learning
experience and hell I should actually
say yes go into empty parks try to build
buildings with a theme if you haven't
done it before because if you do
something like that then at least you
won't waste your time with buildings
that you're eventually removed and
you'll go into the theme fully prepared
and maybe so because sometimes this
happens you open up the empty sandbox
you decide to mess with the theme you've
never tried before and something great
comes out you can just save the building
a user in your park later on so
everybody wins and that's just a small
tip that I would like to give to not be
me not screw up and just do things in a
neat and organized way that actually
works so
this over here I don't know why but at
some point I felt like yeah I want some
kind of little hand some kind of little
bar outside of this building just with
little stools and chairs and just a bar
just an outside little bar because I
felt like no you kind of have that in
the Mediterranean area sometimes like
these very small restaurants like you
don't really see them and they're just
along the outskirts of the really
tourist tourist attractions but they're
so small and cute and they always have
great food basically that's the ideal
situation that's the kind of serious
site that I'd stereotype that I have in
my head but that's the kind of thing
that I wanted to have it don't know if
anybody understands me probably not
because I'm I'm really talking gibberish
right now but that was the idea I had
there but that was removed anyway so
yeah oh yeah I cry every time when that
happens by the way I just left this
building this building kind of
unfinished when it comes to this side
because I was really undecided about
what the final fate of the building was
going to be and I needed to move on to
this stuff the planning right here
because that needed to happen I really
needed to get some planning down in this
park
just see what else I can do with it now
I do realize that I did skip a bit of
the time lapse over here and I'm very
sorry I actually forgot to record over
there and that was a really terrible
thing I should not do something like
that and I'm really terrible at
remembering anything in my life
but this area it's just okay there's a
couple of things that I'm kind of
worried about when it comes to this area
it's the fact that I feel like that
might there may not be enough space
actually build anything substantial over
here since you know that's that Lake
ish thing River I don't even know what
to call it a body of water over there
because water is cool and there is the
train rail which kind of marks the
border of the park by the way this park
is not going to be a complete circle
I definitely don't want to do something
like that there's gonna be some areas
that are going to be slightly larger
than other areas especially when they
have a mixture of many themes I
definitely think that the Alpine ish
area and the Japanese ish area will be
the largest areas of the park and they
may actually have their respective
consoles but doesn't tell me to not talk
about right now this is basically going
to be the Mediterranean area with its
main attraction just a very small
bloom still don't know exactly how I'm
going to fit that in but basically it's
going to have the small lake in the
middle kind of like Chiapas and have
some facades around bats and the
splashdown is going to be right in the
middle of that thing and it's gonna do
some shenanigans on a mountain and those
rocks right there are just a little
placeholder for the future mountain that
is hopefully actually going to look okay
and that is basically how this area is
going to work out but that's also it for
this episode so thank you for watching
and I'll see you all next episode in
which I'm going to do I don't even know
yet because I haven't recorded it yet
I really need to start working on this
park again because I haven't really done
anything in it yet in any case our
videos in and see you space cowboys